Speaker 1: All right, let's get into audience
questions for the week, much to discuss today,
I got so many messages about this that I will talk
about it. It wasn't part of my coverage on Monday
of Donald Trump's speech because it wasn't
actually something that happened. But I got
so many emails saying, David, is it true
that Donald Trump wore his pants backwards
at that crazy speech in North Carolina? It is
not true. But listen, I understand what's going
on. Trump came up to the stage and we're going to
show a picture of it. And his pants just looked
strange. There were weird creases on the
front. It almost looked like there were
like there was no zipper, like there was just a
seam. And there was speculation his pants were
backwards or it was some kind of a mermaid outfit
or he was wearing an elastic waistband. And that's
why there was no zipper. I have to tell you, when
I looked at it closely, the wrinkles looked like
Trump had just been sitting and the pants are
wrinkly. And I do see what looks like a zipper
crease, although it's not as noticeable maybe
as some others would, I would imagine it to be.
And I didn't for a second think that Donald Trump
wore his pants backwards. This was then looked
at by Snopes and Snopes did indeed determine no,
Trump did not wear his pants backward at the rally
you asked. So we watched the 90 minute speech and
they found that the photograph simply do not show
that Trump's pants were backwards. Now, it's the
funny thing to me about this is, first of all,
the idea that we many of us would believe
that Trump might wear his pants backwards
like that wouldn't be beyond the realm
of possibility. I would believe it.
It just happened not to have been the case. But
the more interesting thing was how low is the bar
that a lot of the commentary is, including
my own on Twitter, when when I saw this
were essentially lizanne, the speech was deranged.
Trump lied throughout it. He told corrosive lies
about democracy. He did all of these things,
but his pants weren't on backwards. And I think
it was Lucas Grindley from The Advocate, if I
recall correctly, who responded to me and said,
this is how low the bar now is, that we can
say at least the guy's pants were on straight,
but no, his pants were forward. I don't
really care about Donald Trump's clothing.
I've never understood from a very just practical
perspective, a guy as wealthy as Trump claims
to be or as wealthy as Trump is. They're not
the same thing, but he's still a wealthy guy.
How has no one gone to him and said, sir, the full
seat suit look is not in right now. The tailored,
slimmer fit looks and or maybe they have. And
Trump doesn't look right in the slimmer fit suits.
I've never understood how a guy this wealthy has
such terrible suits, but I know that Trump's an
older guy and that's a style that there are
other older men I know who still like the
full seat suit. And that appears to be Trump. But
his pants were on forward as far as we can tell.